hu
passons
à l'aéroport de philadelphie elle
arpente les couloirs d'un pas empressés
kenndal wright 38 ans executive woman
des années 2010
il faut beaucoup marché est fier mais
c'est ça qui m'aide à rester en forme
parce que je fais la navette toute la
journée
le briefing de 1h15 on se retrouve là
bas
depuis six ans kendall travaille pour
une grande compagnie aérienne américaine
elle est chef d'equipe
plutôt souriante elle affiche une grande
confiance en elle et semble n'avoir
aucun mal à se faire entendre
merci à tous d'être venus aujourd'hui
on voudrait que vous suiviez la
procédure pour les annonces de passes
rapides
et aussi la semaine prochaine il y aura
un retour
pour avoir un peu plus d'observations
sur la façon dont marche c'est parce
vous avez des questions
le fait d'avoir atteint mes objectifs
ça m'a donné un regard neuf et positif
sur ma vie tous les matins j'ai plaisir
à me réveiller j'aime ce que j'ai
accompli et j'aime mon boulot
ces objectifs atteints dont parle
kendall ne sont pas seulement
professionnelle en dix ans elle a
beaucoup changé
les autorités municipales viennent de
lancer un vaste programme pour perdre du
poids parmi les nombreux participants
kendall wright elle a 27 ans elle pèse
110 kg la prise de contact est un peu
rude mais pour elle hors de question de
baisser les bras
maintenant y arriver
[Musique]
je n'arrivais même plus à me souvenir de
l'époque où j'avais fait un effort pour
la dernière fois j'étais avachis devant
la télé lorsque j'ai vu la marche du
maire
alors je me suis dit pourquoi pas
prendre une journée aller là bas faire
un peu de sport
je voulais perdre 18 kilos alors j'ai
encore du boulot pour y arriver mais kg
après kg c'est faisable
je suis fatigué au lit je dois peser au
moins 100 kg
visionnage avec des collègues qui ne la
connaissait pas à l'époque
[Rires]
c'est pas toi c'est pas possible
on dirait un gros ballons roses
aux mondieux regarde moi ce cumul mais
c'est un cauchemar
ok c'est bon vous êtes contente
tu es si belle mme
un compliment a priori anodin mais qui
lui va droit au coeur
car depuis qu'elle a perdu 40 kilos
kendall à rattraper des décennies de
coquetterie
une des choses que j'aime faire le plus
maintenant c'est d'acheter des
chaussures et
ses plus de son père
alors j'aime aussi les ceintures avec
des tas de trucs brillant dessus en
deuil à la shem betty boop je les aime
beaucoup
kendall wright où l'élégance se
retrouver mais au-delà de cette success
story la majorité des 26 mille candidats
au régime at elle gagné son pari la
ville at-elle vaincu l'obésité
nous n'avons pas impression en nous
promenant dans les rues
dans les quartiers nord de philadelphie
nous avons rendez vous avec une autre
ancienne participante du programme
municipal
d'accord elle s'appelle joyce link est
là la démarche malaisé et le souffle
court
une simple promenade est pour elle un
chemin de croix
il ya un club de gym mais s'ajuste là
un club que joyce fréquentait il n'y a
pas si longtemps
aujourd'hui elle n'y va plus
ouah tout ce matériel
les séances de sport trop intense lui
sont formellement déconseillés
mon médecin dit que je peux travailler
le haut du corps mais pas le bas parce
que je ne dois pas mettre de tension sur
mes genoux
en 2001 joyce tenait une forme olympique
elle venait de perdre pas moins de 22
kilos en trois mois à peine
son employeur une compagnie d'assurances
autoriser les séances de gym sur les
heures de travail
lorsque vous le souhaitez l'entreprise
vous soutient et vous aide à perdre du
poids elle vous encourager ses seuls
vrais trucs
à l'époque elle partageait des repas de
légumes avec ses collègues
et en cas de fringale au travail elle
était fière de montrer ses astuces coupe
faim avant mes tiroirs était plein de
chips et de quatre
et voilà ce que je mange maintenant
quand j'ai faim
et là il ya matière et toutes sortes de
thé d'été naturel d'été pour le régime
[Musique]
dix ans plus tard joyce a repris tous
les kilos perdus et même un peu plus
regardez-moi ça mon dieu
trop de cheveux
joyce est désormais à la retraite elle
mène une vie tranquille avec sa soeur
cathy
quand elle invite une amie à déjeuner
elles peuvent lui servir une soupe comme
une réminiscence des années régime
c'est une soupe et pinard carottes pas
de viande sauf qu'aujourd'hui les
légumes voisine avec une nourriture
beaucoup moins sun tu as apporté les
sandwichs
confirmation dans le frigo la diététique
appartient bel et bien au passé
c'est du port et de la choucroute on a
fait ça vendredi et l'autre jour j'ai
fait du chili il n'y a pas de glace
parce que j'ai tout mangé cette nuit
et maintenant il faut que j'aille au
magasin pour refaire le plein
même la chienne a sa propre glace la
glace spéciale pour chiens
en réalité joyce a baissé les bras après
seulement quelques mois d'efforts cette
ligne qu'elle avait brièvement retrouvé
elle en a fait son deuil j'en ai marre
de tous ces régimes parce qu'il ne
marche pas tu as vu ça ne marche
vraiment pas ça ne marche que sur le
moment un mois ou deux on perd 10 ou 15
kilos et il ya un moment où on se remet
à manger normalement
17 secondes là on reprend du poids guy
bono ils sont juste là pour vous faire
payer pour le régime est payé pour leur
nourriture spéciale et quand c'est fini
il n'y a personne pour vous conseiller
personne
c'est juste une affaire de sous big
business
dire qu'il y a dix ans joyce s'était
fait l'avocate des régimes une avocate
très fervente elle osait même abordé le
maire de la ville pour lui raconter son
expérience
quand son entreprise recevait un prix
c'est elle qui était sur scène
[Musique]
et nous voulons les distinguer
voici donc la récompense
merci
joyce faisait la une de la presse locale
tout comme gwen foster l'organisatrice
du programme alors quel bilan sa
diététicienne tire-t-elle aujourd'hui de
la cure d'amaigrissement de philadelphie
réussite ou échec
[Musique]
c'est dans cette église de la communauté
adventiste que nous avons retrouvé guen
foster
elle dirige la chorale
elle ne travaille plus pour la ville la
nouvelle majorité municipale a enterré
le plan des 76 tonnes 7 à titre privé
que la diététicienne continuent de
combattre l'obésité à travers l'église
adventiste
[Musique]
dix ans après notre premier reportage
guan foster l'admet le plan des 76
tonnes était avant tout une opération de
communication
il était irréaliste visaient des
résultats trop rapide
on a perdu le poids en fait on a perdu
76 tonnes de graisse mais en plus de
temps que prévu elle nous a pris deux
mois de plus
moi je n'étais pas vraiment favorable à
cette opération
parce que je voulais pas que les
philadelphie en perdre du poids d'une
façon pas très saine un peu comme ces
régimes rapide à la française
du coup la situation n'était pas bonne
avant mais c'est encore pire aujourd'hui
où l'obésité continue à se répandre
maintenant on se rencontre on a fait une
erreur avec cette opération
résultat 30 % des philadelphien sont
aujourd'hui obèses contre 20% il ya dix
ans du coup guen foster a opté pour une
nouvelle méthode l'amincissement en
douceur
elle organise des cours de yoga à
l'opposé des sports violents que les
obèses pratiqué il ya dix ans
j'ai beau t-shirt malheureusement le
groupe d'hier a pris les plus grands
donc les plus grands que nous ayons sont
les xl ce que je vous conseille c'est de
prendre des ciseaux et de couper sur
chaque côté
comme ça ça va les élargir un peu
[Musique]
[Rires]
certains participants sont presque
invalides comme bill un diabétique et sa
femme mary
c'est notre objectif
qu'est ce que c'est votre objectif
de rentrer dedans
le moindre geste requiert beaucoup
d'efforts
ça va
c'est plus dur que ça en a l'air
oui je dois juste faire attention à ne
pas dépasser mes limites
je ne suis pas capable de faire ces
choses là maintenant mais j'y travaille
j'avance à petit par
comme chaque participant bill et mairies
sont suivis au quotidien par des coachs
des coaches qui savent de quoi ils
parlent
denise par exemple est une ancienne
obèse elle a perdu pas moins de 60 kg
elle veut offrir aux couples le dvd
qu'elle a tiré de son histoire
je m'en suis remise à la bible et j ai
trouvé tous les passages sur le courage
je sais que c'est un long chemin pour
vous mais à travers dieu tout est
possible
dieu vous bénisse et j'espère que vous
me contacterait
témoigner pour s'entraider c'est le
principe clé de la méthode foster
une fois par mois la diététicienne
réunit un cercle de personnes en
surpoids pour libérer la parole à la
manière des alcooliques anonymes
ce soir elle va inciter bill le
diabétique à se livrer en public
l'enjeu pour bill c'est qu'on allait lui
couper les pieds afin là j'ai compris
que j'étais confronté à un choix
je me suis dit qu'il était temps de me
faire une raison
j'en avais besoin pas seulement pour la
santé mais pour mon bien-être en général
et donc dit la trouver la motivation est
maintenant regarder le résultat
depuis le début de son régime bill a
déjà perdu 20 kilos le seul chiffre que
cet homme pudique consentira à donner
sur son poids
[Musique]
dernier pilier de la méthode foster
apprendre aux obèses à cuisiner un ou
deux plats pas plus comme ces pâtes aux
légumes dont elle distribue la recette
gêne et à notre chef vous apprendra les
principes de base et vous vous devrez
essayer de transmettre ça à quelqu'un
c'est comme ça qu'on va progresser ok
[Musique]
pour les participants dégustez une
simple soupe au quinoa est un véritable
événement ce soir jennifer fait la
distribution elle aussi fut obèses dans
une autre vie comme tous les assistants
de gwen foster
vous vous sentez mieux depuis que vous
mangez sainement beaucoup et j'ai aussi
entrepris la gym ces deux activités
ensemble que je mène en parallèle ça a
vraiment amélioré ma vie
pourquoi les occasions de manger
sainement sont elles si rare pour ces
philadelphien
comment expliquer que l'obésité n'ai
cessé de progresser
le lendemain nous retrouvons jennifer
bon je vais tourner sur l'avenue girard
et je vais longer la limite sud de la
ville elle veut nous montrer ce qui est
selon elle à l'origine du problème dans
les quartiers populaires
africaines kentucky fried chicken
mcdonald's
regardez le genre de commerce qu'on a
autour de nous
dix ans après notre premier reportage à
philadelphie les fast-foods n'ont cessé
de gagner du terrain
comme vous le voyez il n'y a absolument
rien qu'on puisse acheter les produits
du coup la plupart des gens de quartier
devront prendre un bus ou conduire pour
aller au supermarché
sinon ils ne pourront pas trouver
facilement de la nourriture saine
donc ce quartier c'est vraiment un foot
désert
totalement
un foot déserte littéralement un désert
alimentaire
d'après jennifer les magasins qui
vendent des produits frais s'implante
uniquement dans les quartiers riches
est-il vraiment impossible de bien
manger dans ce foot déserte nous
accompagnons jennifer
première halte un corner store une
épicerie où tout le quartier fait ses
courses zéro légumes et des milliers de
boîtes de conserves sauce soda chips le
tout à bas prix les clients ne demandent
pas autre chose
c'est l'idéal en paye par avec la
saucisse jamais ça celle là aussi
ça et en plus ces régimes
deuxième halte un fast food
d'après une étude la restauration rapide
sera responsable à 68% de l'obésité des
américains
dans la carte jennifer cherche
désespérément un plat qui lui
conviennent
[Musique]
je crois que la seule chose que je
puisse trouver là ce sont des bâtonnets
de l'église
mais je crois que les bâtonnets de
légumes c'est un peu comme les frites
ils les font frire j'ai l'impression
qu'il n'y a pas grand chose de sain ici
au final deux ou trois légumes qui se
battent en duel
voilà c'est ça que j'ai commandé sexe
des bâtonnets de céleri et des carottes
etc sans ça
je crois que pour les carottes et le
céleri si ok
mais c'est vraiment tout ce qu'il y a
le pire pour jennifer sait qu'à
philadelphie la spécialité culinaire
n'est rien d'autre qu'un sandwich
le philly cheesesteak
jusqu'à 1000 calories plus du tiers des
besoins quotidiens en quelques bouchées
et voilà c'est ça le cheesecake
l'endroit le plus fameux pourront
déguster un c'est chez jean aux une
institution à philadelphie
il y a dix ans nous étions déjà venus
interroger jo vento célèbre patron et
fondateur de l'établissement sur la
responsabilité des fast food dans
l'obésité
voulait des légumes parfois aller voir
ailleurs ce pays est né avec le boeuf on
a été élevé au boeuf je suis j'ai un
mangeur de boeuf et de patates regardez
moi j'ai 62 ans ça fait 40 ans que je
mange des cheesesteak geiler rom est
peut-être
est idiot il ne travaille plus ici non
jo est mort le 23 août et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il a eu une crise cardiaque
vous savez pourquoi non en fait il était
relativement en bonne santé enfin c'est
ce qu'on pensait répond cet hiver est
loin
et puis il ya eu cette attaque deux
salles à emporter
impossible de savoir si cette crise
cardiaque est liée au régime alimentaire
dont joe vento nous faisait l'apologie
une chose est sûre son décès n'a pas
fait chuter le chiffre d'affaires
il faut dire que le prix du sandwich
restent attractifs à partir de 5 $ pour
la même somme vous n'aurez que de bottes
de brocolis ou encore un petit kilo de
carottes et un kilo de chou si vous
réussissez à les trouver
difficile avec de tels prix d'imposer
les légumes dans les corners store
démonstration avec le foot trust une
association qui a pris le relais de la
municipalité pour mener le combat contre
l'obésité
les militants n'hésitent pas à payer de
leur personne et pourquoi vous n'étiez
pas l'attraper les gens qui sortent du
bus la
succès mitigé
acheter au stand
10 achetés au
samedi acheter au stade zabana
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
initiative je pense que c'est très bien
souvent on ne mange pas sainement
et dans le voisinage je vous en trouvez
des légumes à toujours
vous savez souvent c'est cher et sinon
on n'en trouve pas
l'offensive continue à l'intérieur des
corners store
cette militante a convaincu l'épicière
de vendre des fruits à l'unité et une
salade
un exploit
au début j'avais peur que ça me prenne
trop de temps j'avais peur que ça ne
marche pas il faut acheter un frigo et
on ne sait pas si on va rentabiliser
au début je ne voulais pas le faire il
faut une heure et demie pour couper les
fruits
finalement question pris tout le monde
s'y retrouve les clients comme
l'épicière
la salade de fruits ces deux dollars et
c'est une affaire parce qu'au
supermarché vous l'aurez pour 3,99 à
4,99
cela vous en avez deux pour un dollar je
crois que nous faisons vraiment des bons
prix ça arrange tout le monde pour les
habitués du corner store c'est une
révolution culturelle oui la salade de
fruits c'est beau vous devriez essayer
oui elle aime mes fruits frais un jour
elle m'a demandé si les morceaux venait
d'une boîte de conserve
j'ai dit non elle mais veut couper les
fruits ah bon vous coupez les fruits
vous même
[Musique]
l'intention est bonne mais ce petit
frigo semble encore bien perdu dans un
océan de canettes et de boîtes de
conserve
[Musique]
si les produits frais n'attire pas les
philadelphien c'est donc parce qu'ils
sont chers et introuvable alors geoff
bowen l'homme à la veste de jean
s'attaque de front à ces deux problèmes
avec son association il demande aux
autorités de subventionner les légumes
et il part faire les marchés au coeur
des quartiers défavorisés
direction camden juste de l'autre côté
du pont en face de philadelphie
[Musique]
ken de nombreux nous allons les gens
sont en général assez pauvre
c'est un quartier qu'à l'état de
problèmes économiques et de clean alité
depuis longtemps
je sais qu à camden ils n'ont vraiment
pas accès aux produits frais il ya très
peu de supermarchés
camden et donc là encore un foot déserte
le petit groupe a installé son stand
dans la rue principale
mais au bout d'une dizaine de minutes il
faut se rendre à l'évidence les vendeurs
éveil tout juste la curiosité des
passants
ça ne les intéresse vraiment pas on peut
passer des heures à rabâcher on peut
même leur proposer de l'argent ça ne
changera rien
car les activistes du foot trust ont
obtenu des autorités que les fruits et
légumes des marchés puissent être
achetées avec des bons alimentaires
à camden la ville en délivre à plus d'un
tiers des habitants
pendant longtemps ces bons n'était
valable que dans les fast food et les
supermarchés
malgré ces aides les ventes de légumes
ne décolle pas
la nourriture industrielle et plus
facile d'accès elle est moins chère
bon c'est vrai que le gouvernement donne
des tapes subventions à l'agriculture
industrielle
et de l'autre côté il fait un tout petit
geste avec ces bons d'achat
c'est ridicule comparé à l'argent dont
bénéficie l'agriculture industrielle
donc c'est un combat inégal
du coup jawf et son association peine à
équilibrer les comptes
si le programme ne marche pas
financièrement
faut quand même que ce soit rentable
donc si ça ne marche pas mieux je crois
qu'ils arrêteront l'année prochaine
j'espère qu'on continuera
j'ai des doutes
des militants prêts à jeter les armes
des habitants qui rejette la nourriture
saine presque par habitude
si ces américains changer leurs
comportements alimentaires cela
prendrait sans doute des années
pour kendall il a fallu près de dix ans
au cours de notre premier reportage nous
l'avions suivi au début d'un difficile
apprentissage
bien sûr les sodas s'est terminée il ya
trop dessus je vais boire plus d'eau
plus de glace non plus
tiens je pourrais prendre du pop corn
alléger
slight
50% moins gras candle ne sait pas encore
lire entre les lignes du marketing
pourtant en faisant appel à son esprit
critique elles sont bien que la partie
n'est pas gagnée
je ne suis pas sûr de ce qu'il faut
acheter ou pas qu'est ce qui est sain de
ce qui ne l'est pas
je sais que les fast food les gâteaux le
coup qu'ils tout ça ce n'est pas bon
mais il faut que je me mette à cuisiner
différemment par exemple cuir mais
animant four au lieu de les faire frire
et voilà il faut changer comme ça jour
après jour et peu à peu je vais y
arriver
depuis ken dahl a parcouru un long
chemin
c'était un combat parce qu'il a fallu
que je change totalement de style de vie
j'ai dû apprendre à penser différemment
à agir différemment en fait j'ai dû
changer toutes les habitudes qu'il avait
rendues obèses
la première des choses que kendall a
changé c'est sa cuisine
elle a investi dans un équipement
flambant neuf et puis fini les corners
store elles n'achètent plus les mêmes
produits il faut dire que son nouveau
travail dans la compagnie aérienne lui
rapporte 4000 $ par mois
un veau là j'ai quelques jours de bon là
j'ai du poisson je peux le manger avec
les légumes que je veux j'en mange tout
le temps je peux le frire le faire
bouillir ou le panais
déjà je n'utilise plus les huiles
classique
j'ai changé pour l'huile d'olive
c'est vraiment plus léger j'en utilise
fréquemment
est une chose dont je me sers pour
cuisiner c'est ce plat qui n'accroche
pas mais je peux offrir quelque chose
dans très peu d'huile
et c'est vraiment toujours très bon
au début j'étais un peu découragé par
les prix des produits frais mais si vous
regardez sur le long terme je préfère
investir dans ce que je mange et être en
bonne santé
plutôt que d'acheter de la nourriture
bon marché et être grosse
si en l'espace de dix ans kendall a pu
perdre 40 kg ce n'est pas seulement
parce que son niveau de vie s'est
améliorée pour comprendre son succès il
faut revenir aux confidences qu'elle
nous faisaient à l'époque elle n'a pas
l'intention d'abandonner mais elle elle
a une bonne raison
oui parce que moi j'ai un but je veux
maigrir
parce que je veux devenir militaire
mais bon avant de rentrer dans l'armée
il faut perdre du poids
[Musique]
à
aujourd'hui il suffit de lire les quatre
lettres imprimées sur le jogging de
kendall pour comprendre qu'elle a
réalisé son rêve elle est devenue
réservistes dans l'armée américaine
elle a réussi son examen il ya trois ans
tout comme l'ami avec qui elle
s'entraîne chaque semaine c'est pour se
glisser dans l'uniforme que kendall a
changé de silhouette
j'avais une vraie volontaire j'avais ça
très profond en moi pour réaliser les
objectifs que je m'étais fixé
ça m'a permis d'aller de l'avant et
d'atteindre mon but c'est ce qui m'a
permis de devenir un soldat de l'armée
américaine
c'est vraiment tout ça qui m'a motivé et
c'est grâce à ça que j'ai pu réussir
tout ce que j'ai entrepris ensuite
[Applaudissements]
un objectif à atteindre c'est sans doute
ce qui a manqué à joyce link pour
persévérer dans sa perte de poids
sa vieille mère remue régulièrement le
couteau dans la plaie
les discussions sont animées
non on veut savoir ton opinion pourquoi
les gens mangent trop
tu la connais
d'après toi pourquoi les gens mangent
trop parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
contrôler vos observations
j'ai 89 ans j'ai eu huit enfants
et je fais le même poids que lorsque
j'étais en terminale en 1941
si tu veux perdre du poids alors tu en
perds bras je sais que tu peux perdre du
poids si tu le veux vraiment
tout ce business autour de la dépression
je n'y crois pas
tu ne crois pas qu'il y a des gens qui
déprime vraiment
non vraiment pas ils choisissent d'être
déprimé oui
et tu ne crois pas qu'ils petit d'y
avoir un rapport avec ce qu'ils vivent
si quelqu'un devait être déprimé ici ça
devrait être moi oui très déprimé je
n'ai pas envie de voir mes filles mourir
avant moi et c'est une chose possible si
elle n'écoute pas ce qu'on leur dit
des mots durs à entendre
un malaise familiale qui a sans doute
favorisé la boulimie de joyce
comme manager
savent à la
bienvenue dans mon parti
want some celui qui veut une petite
douceur
moralité pour maigrir il faut de la
stabilité et de l'estimé de soi il y a
des beignets au sucre glace à la
cannelle
d'autres avec du sucre en poudre et de
la crème fraîche
et ce qui est valable pour joyce l'est
sans doute pour toute la nation
celui là il
une amérique déprimée par des années de
crise aura bien du mal à régler le
problème de son obésité
pas belle la vie